[Music]
there's like a strong violent culture in
Africa as a whole being able to see the
violent culture in all of these
different ways it just resonated with me
because I am african-american and I know
that my African research from somewhere
it just opened up my whole mind to the
idea of violence and like what you can
do with this my name is Sudan archives
and I am a finger song writer producer
and violinist from Cincinnati Ohio my
songs are all about textures it's just
one idea with all of these ways to get
different sounds my songs usually start
with my violin and then once I find like
a idea on the violin I usually have like
my Loop Station with me I'm able to just
add more layers and more layers and more
layers to that I can pitch the octave
down I can just make it sound like an
accordion or a wind instrument being
able to have technology it's probably
why I'm able to like be a solo artist
because I wouldn't be able to do all
these things at once this is my song not
for sale off my EP sink
this is my kitchen this is a start song
I usually start with violin the whole
format of not for sale is just this
simple violin riff the style of the
plucking came from like my little
background all the other melodic parks
are basically variations of that riff my
parents raised us and like this strict
church environment my biological dad as
a preacher like behind a revival first
isn't write pages about of my stepdad he
was a music producer he really wanted me
to pursue music he just really pushed
like the creative side of me baroque
violin shop is a store in Cincinnati
[Music]
I first got into violin because the
owner at baroque violin shop came to my
school and played the cello played the
violin and had this like really cool
story with it but also like using loop
stations and effect pedals that was when
I was like okay I need to get a violin
[Music]
I'd still be they condone as a waitress
either something or an insult at school
maybe if I didn't keep playing violin
and my keep experimenting but the thing
was it wasn't that I played by LAN it
looks like seeing you and seeing these
different kinds of violin players
because not just Orchestra settings like
yeah man my phone it's really it's music
yeah it's not we really couldn't even
afford violin lessons my mom suggested
that I play with the choir at my church
there was no other like violinist up
there so then I eventually developed a
sense of ear when someone just says
anything I'm able to like play the same
thing there's kind of only three parts
to the song which is violin bass and
drums
whatever riff I'm playing one of those
notes is going to be the bass line
[Laughter]
all the other parts of the song that
aside from violin are just kind of like
simple variations to just kind of
amplify it definitely like the drums
like if I want to be like doing clap and
the bass on the verse it was an electric
bass but on the pre hook it changes into
this sub electronic bass I create all of
those ideas with the violin and then I
just kind of like follow the lead of the
violin with other electronic instruments
in the computer Lord we thank you for
this food that we're about to be see for
the nourishment of our bodies in
Christ's name we pray amen amen
I never really liked my name Brittany
and I was a mama I really like my name
she was like what about Sudan so I
started going by Sudan
actually my mom everyone just calls me
Sudan one day I just decided to just
check out the music in Sudan and I found
all of this really cool music and
there's like a strong violin culture in
Sudan specifically but also in Africa as
a whole I changed it to sit on archives
because of this like ethnomusicologist
she specifically like studies like West
Africans fiddling and they're playing
all these crazy like in harmonics and
all the stuff which isn't one string
[Music]
there was like never really any other
black people playing violins so when I
saw like people in Africa planet that
looked like me that makes me feel really
good for some reason maybe I'm not an
outcast once I changed my name to Sudan
archives it just kind of started to
click and it kind of made me want to
keep practicing violin because there's
so many different ways you could play it
[Music]
you shouldn't think about itself hard
it's just self-expression I was like
okay there's no excuse to not keep going
you can literally teach yourself or make
up your own style
[Music]
the lyrics are kind of self-explanatory
but I was just feeling a little you know
used at the time it was like mainly just
about my close relationships but then
it's like a bigger picture to it
the whole morale of it is just like
knowing your self-worth this is my this
is my kitchen too
this is my time don't waste it up this
is my land not for sale you can't buy me
you can't sell me can't trade me can't
be me
so stop painting the word not came from
a sign I saw in Ghana it was like a big
piece of land I was like what is that
sign and they were like oh it's just
someone bought the land and they're just
saying it's not for sale so I was like
oh that's that's lit it's like an ode to
my first trip to Africa and that was my
first plane ride off the country as well
so now I have that memory forever this
is my time don't we
[Music]
a lot of people say like when they see
me on stage by myself trigging
everything multitasking doing it all is
something inspiring to them I hope that
it can inspire people to do that in
their own way whatever they're doing I
want to create new ideas with my music
[Music]